all right moving on to mother's day the
countdown is officially on and don
mccarthy of dawn's corner is sharing
some unique gift ideas for that special
mother figure in your life
good afternoon las vegas now with
mother's day just around the corner i
have something special for the moms that
like to cook
thanks to top chef marcel vigneron who
competed in food networks tournament of
champions iron chef and bravo's top chef
i have you covered he is the chef behind
this beautiful
hammered cookware collection that makes
a statement turning any kitchen into a
culinary masterpiece
this cookware is always non-stick
lightweight scratch resistant and
dishwasher safe
or greenick pans are also oven safe up
to 500 degrees fahrenheit and suitable
for all stove types including gas glass
and ceramic there are great recipes
online for mom to try as well and the
best part they're so affordable for
instance a three piece set is under 85
dollars and the color options it's gonna
be hard to pick a favorite
go to original or greenick.com to order
some new cookware for mom today
now sticking with my cooking theme we
all love fried foods or at least i do
but cleaning up after frying can truly
be messy so what do you do with leftover
cooking oil i mean you can't put it down
the drain fry away to the rescue for mom
fry away is a plant-based non-toxic
powder under 10 bucks that magically
transforms used cooking oil into solid
organic waste just simply stir into the
hot oil let it cool so that it can
easily just be tossed into the household
trash can so go ahead fry away they have
you covered
do something good for the planet and mom
to order a bag go to amazon.com or
fryaway.co
next flattes the only handcrafted flat
candles handmade by artisans in
lithuania these unique flat hand painted
candles are made to gift inside a
greeting card
this modern designed candle is smokeless
scentless self-extinguishing and drip
resistant a base is included with every
candle and the candles are under 16
dollars and can even be gift wrapped
with a personalized message for a little
more and sent directly to your loved
ones and of course mom i was truly so
excited to receive this product as a
gift myself and i just had to share
i love candles but they were always so
expensive and heavy to ship
not anymore thanks to flat tees online
that's f l a t y z
online dot com
lastly with the nice weather in vegas
maul will be out and about for
activities and it's important to keep
hydrated to feel your best
i recommend trying 305 life a wellness
brand that celebrates the ethos and
outdoor lifestyle of miami and was
created by mr 305 himself
singer-songwriter pitbull
305 life comes in three flavors everyday
life raspberry guava recovery pineapple
coconut and energy acai punch it's
simple just mix one packet per day with
12 ounce of still or sparkling water or
even add to your favorite shake a box is
60 and includes 30 packets so it's a
month supply go to 305-life dot com to
get a box today if you want more
information on any of these products i
just featured go to dawnscorner.com
happy mother's day to all moms and to my
mom like many others who are in heaven
we love and miss you
oh